uh the office of conservative cheap whip
Chris Heaton Harris says he's in
investigating reports that a
conservative MP watch pornography on his
phone in the Commons chamber a statement
from the conservative whips office said
the chief whip is looking into this
matter this behavior is wholly
unacceptable and action will be taken uh
Beth Rigby uh of course is with me our
political editor we'll get to pmq's uh
Beth but uh extraordinary bit of news
Crossing about a front bench MP no less
uh apparently watching porn in the
Commons chamber yeah this is uh this is
quite a shocking story and it emerged in
a conversation between female MPS last
night and I've had it corroborated uh by
an MP that was in that meeting
and apparently at that meeting a female
minister
said that an MP was watching pornography
next to her so the supposition is it's a
front front bench but that hasn't been
explicitly said
um and a colleague in the room
immediately corroborated that
um I was also told that this Minister
this female Minister
apparently also said that the culprit
had been doing this in committees so in
committee meetings that this had also
happened there so this in terms of her
evidence wasn't the first occasion
um and I've also been told
um that the women that the two MPS have
subsequently spoken to the chief whip
Chris Heaton Harris and Chris Heaton
Harris has made a statement if I can
find it
um he has said so I'm just trying to
find it the chief whip is looking into
this matter this behavior is wholly
unacceptable so apparently the MPS have
named this person to the chief Whip and
they're now looking into it the Prime
Minister has said uh in the comments
just then that sexual harassment is
grounds for dismissal let's see uh what
comes of that but I should also say in
the round of all of this uh Caroline
wheeler the political editor of the
Sunday Times had an exclusive story on
Sunday saying that over 50 MPS were
being investigated for sexual harassment
so a truly shocking story and I think it
will have some way to run and I think
everyone was was pretty amazed that um
female MPS are sharing stories and
experiences like that in the in their
place of work